[Música]
venci estava vindo bem tudo bem
ela pergunta que eu trouxe pra vocês
como os campeões estão decisões nos
momentos mais cruciais essa é uma
pergunta muito importante que ele vê a
vida inteira para responder como foi
apresentado fui atleta foi nadador e
vocês podem olhar que todo o nadador
qualquer pessoa tem um sonho aqui se
fala muito de sonho eo meu sonho era ser
este homem
gustavo borges maior medalhista olímpico
da natação brasileira eu queria seu
gustavo borges e como vocês podem ver no
próximo de live
eu era igual ao gustavo borges tudo a
ver o tamanho biotipo isso aqui é meu
pai e foi ele que vendeu essa ideia joel
seja como o gustavo borges e aqui sou eu
na minha primeira competição eu convido
os senhores a me encontrar nessa foto
onde eu estou
quem é o joel já conseguiram encontrar
na minha primeira competição querendo
seu gustavo borges senhoras e senhores
eu sou este indivíduo aqui então esporte
me mostrar uma realidade muito dura que
ninguém nasce sabendo muito dura e ficou
uma pergunta na minha mente que perdura
até hoje como que os vencedores tomam
decisões como como como a vida inteira
procura entender como que os grandes
vencedores os esportistas vencedores
tomam decisões porque é inegável que
grandes vencedores
eles aparecem em grandes momentos da
minha vida inteira ela está pautada no
estudo e na convivência com os
vencedores
esse aqui são três atletas que eu
reconheço que eu gosto que eu admiro o
primeiro deles é o michael phelps e
nessa minha pergunta do como como que o
michael phelps chegou seu melhor
medalhista o maior de todos o grande
campeão da história de todas as
olimpíadas
tem muita coisa que ele fez e que ele
faz e que algumas pessoas não sabe
a primeira é que ele ficou durante cinco
anos treinando todos os dias enquanto
seus adversários não treinavam no
domingo ele treinava no domingo e ele
dizia o seguinte o final ao final do ano
eu terei de 52 vezes 52 treinos a mais
do que qualquer adversário
meu o que apareceu aqui foi ambiente eu
entendi que os grandes vencedores eles
são forjados em ambientes excepcionais
grandes vencedores estão em ambientes
excepcionais grandes vencedores eles são
cuidados dentro de uma atmosfera que
propicia isso pra eles existem vários
estudos prática deliberada além das 10
mil horas ou dos dez anos eo michael
phelps
ele foi visto desta forma ele é
considerado um grande arquivo worker tem
um outro cara que eu gosto muito é o
bolton enquanto michael phelps foi o
maior medalhista da história de todas as
modalidades desportivas
o bonde ele foi o maior medalhista dos
100 e dos 200 metros no atletismo e
característica que ele tem como que ele
toma decisão eu não sei se você já
praticou o esporte se pratica esporte
mas o bolt ele tem uma característica
incrível ele quando ele vai correr
milhões de pessoas estão assistindo ele
um mundo parou a tv está focada
celulares ligados e ele pede para as
pessoas ficarem em silêncio o bolt ele
não liga para os adversários
o grande vencedor ele não quer ser
bonzinho
o grande vencedor ele não quer ser amado
o grande vencedor ele quer ser
respeitado e ele pede para as pessoas
ficar em silêncio segunda grande
característica dos vencedores
personalidade
eles acreditam neles e tem uma outra
pessoa que eu admiro demais hoje eu
tenho a oportunidade de trabalhar lado a
lado que é o neymar
o neymar eu conheço há quase dez anos e
eu tenho a oportunidade de vivenciar a
vida junto com ele e seus propósitos mas
no final da copa do mundo onde ele fez o
gol ea seleção brasileira foi campeã nas
olimpíadas de 2016 aconteceu algo
inédito
ele foi um dos integrantes da primeira
medalha de ouro do futebol brasileiro em
jogos olímpicos
algumas pessoas não sabem tudo que ele
passou antes ele tem muita facilidade
para chutar com as duas pernas
ele tem muita facilidade para jogar pra
tocar pra fazer gol de cabeça o neymar
ele tem aqui ó recursos porque os
grandes vencedores conseguem tomar
decisões corretas na hora h porque ele
um ambiente moda a personalidade forte e
eles têm muitos recursos hoje neymar ele
consegue chutar com as duas pernas com
muita facilidade como se a perna
esquerda dele fosse como a perna direita
dele e por quê porque ele treina isso
desde pequeno junto com o pai dele junto
com o treinador dele em momentos
cruciais
ele coloca os recursos dele no jogo
ambiente personalidade recursos muito
bem lembra que eu queria ser o gustavo
borges
eu treinei eu fui diversas vezes campeão
até o dia que a gente se encontrou e
esse foi o dia era tudo que eu queria
era tudo que eu desejei meu pai estava
lá
minha mãe estava lá e quando eu fui
competir com gustavo borges
eu perdi feio porque eu pedi permissão
para ganhar dele eu não usei recurso
eu não tive a personalidade embora ter
sido colocado numa situação de bastante
treino intenso um cenário bastante
extraordinário eu não tive todos os
elementos e eu não conseguir vencer o
gustavo borges
ou seja eu
segui ser o gustavo borges que eu tanto
que ser isso foi fotografado em santos
em 2001
esse foi o dia que estamos vendo ali do
lado dele
essa pergunta até então ela começou a
permear a minha cabeça que o einstein e
digo o seguinte olha eu não sou tão
inteligente assim é que eu fico muito
mais tempo na pergunta eu fico muito
mais tempo na pergunta e fiquei o que eu
preciso ter para ser um grande vencedor
como gustavo borges
como eu tenho que pensar e como eu tenho
que agir para ser um grande vencedor
como gustavo borges eu fiquei muito
tempo
nesta pergunta uma vida inteira nessa
pergunta eu cheguei nesta conclusão já
que eu não nasci com as pernas de
campeão que eu tenho uma cabeça de
campeão
muitos anos me envolvendo em estudos de
psicologia de neuromarketing de
programação neurolinguística de coaching
eu fui entendendo para construir a minha
cabeça como a cabeça de um campeão já
que não tinha nascido com os meus dois
metros e quatro como tenham gustavo
borges mas algo aconteceu e eu entendi
diante de novas perguntas o jogo
verdadeiro dos campeões
essa é minha sobrinha ela é filha da
irmã e com dois anos de idade ela fez um
vídeo que ela disse assim que joel você
tem que trabalhar para comprar presente
para mim eu falei alguma coisa tem que
melhorar aqui eu preciso influenciar
mais a minha sobrinha e aos três anos de
idade ela estava segurando este livro do
qual foi coautor e ela segurou
aos quatro anos de idade eu lancei mais
um livro a pergunta era o sucesso é
óbvio um amigo meu me disse joel não
quer o autógrafo seu eu quero autógrafo
da dz
a dise e mordeu a língua e fez um
desenho ao final deste dia memorável ela
chegou para a irmã e falou mamãe eu
quero ser escritora como que o joel
com quatro anos de idade com quatro anos
de idade disse rehn disse que queria ser
uma escritora eu me peguei olha a
influência que eu estou exercendo a
minha sobrinha é muito mais próximo a
mim mesmo nível que em
gustavo borges influenciou a minha vida
o que eu faço agora ano passado eu não
sei mais um livro e não é que ela
escreveu o primeiro livro dela e no
lançamento do meu quarto livro ela fez o
primeiro capítulo e ela disse assim pra
mim é a minha vida é uma correria vou
para a escola chegou à noite às 18 horas
cinco anos de idade
como pode alguém viver uma correria com
cinco anos de idade é comecei a ler um
livro e não terminei mas vou terminar é
muito bom é muito bom seus cursos que o
joel recurso não fez um curso mesmo meu
pai tá ficando doido cada vez que você
dá um curso muda a vida das pessoas e eu
falei para aí alguma coisa acontecendo
aí eu pretendo fazer um curso seu mas
ainda sou criança
não vejo a hora de crescer fico muito
feliz que você está se dando bem
isso é incrível e ela escreveu o
primeiro livro dela eu falei é ela
escreveu o primeiro livro dela a minha
pergunta foi o que eu tenho que
responder para minha sobrinha eu tenho
que responder para ela que ela tem que
ser uma escritora como um tio dela ou eu
tenho que responder que ela tem que ser
uma escritora como ela porque alguém
pediu para o seu gustavo borges
mas eu não consegui ser o meu nome é
joel e odeia gostava eu tenho um metro e
38 ele tem dois metros e 4 ele é tão
grande que se ele tiver pregando aqui um
quadro e um martelo cair ele segura o
quadro e pega o martelo no chão ele é
enorme e eu não consigo fazer isso e é
determinante envergadura dele eu lembrei
de novo desta pergunta eu tenho que
saber fazer a pergunta certa pra ter a
resposta certa e eu entendi que a
pergunta é né
não é como os vendedor os vencedores
tomam as suas decisões na hora h a
pergunta não é como muita gente fala pra
você o que você tem que fazer por
exemplo você tem que desenvolver o seu
propósito
tem que ser um pouco mais profunda como
que eu chego no meu propósito me da
ferramenta mim poderá mas eu fui mais a
fundo
não é como eles tomam decisão é porque
eles tom aquela decisão
e quando eu fiz essa pergunta que levou
anos para fazer nessa atmosfera neste
envolvimento
eu cheguei neste jogo aqui os grandes
vencedores
eles não querem ser vencedores eles
querem ter progresso eles querem
melhorar a cada dia cada dia eles querem
ser melhores em do que os outros a cada
dia ele quer melhorar um pouquinho mais
um pouquinho é o jogo do progresso e tem
uma outra grande questão que pouca
pessoa que diz eu vou te dizer se você
perguntar pra mim
joel porque que os vencedores tomam as
decisões como eles tomam eu tenho a
humildade de falar pra você
não sei muita gente sobe aqui e fala o
que você tem que fazer eu vou subir aqui
e vou falar que eu não sei mas eu tenho
uma hipótese e se você quiser testar
essa hipótese
eu vou te dar a minha fala o meu o meu
achado a minha opinião que é o que eu
acredito
muitas pessoas vivem a vida inteira
querendo ser quem elas não são
eu vivi a minha vida inteira querendo
ser o gustavo borges
mas eu não sou gustavo borges eu não
tenho o tamanho dele eu não tenho uma
estrutura física dele
sabe por que esses grandes vencedores
são vencedores
é simples a decisão deles porque tanto o
michael phelps quanto o bote e quanto
neymar fazem a única coisa que eles
sabem fazer melhor
eles não perdem o tempo fazendo outra
coisa eu tenho certeza que cada um que
tá me ouvindo aqui faz algo melhor do
que todos os outros álbuns que você faz
tem algo dentro de você tem algo no seu
comportamento que você faz
é melhor do que tudo só que eu não tenho
certeza se você trabalha com isso ou se
você vive com isso porque esses caras
tomam as decisões porque eles não têm
outra escolha eles fazem a natação ou o
atletismo ou o futebol porque a única
coisa que eles fazem bem e porque a
gente fica perdendo tempo fazendo aquilo
que a gente não faz bem
isso é meio estranho chega a ser até
estúpido a gente fica fazendo coisas que
a gente não sabe fazer
por motivos que a gente não sabe
entender e que na maioria dos casos são
motivos externos e não motivo interno
até o dia do lançamento do meu livro ea
minha sobrinha me disse tio eu quero ser
escritora
como você ea resposta foi você vai ser
mas não como tio como você você vai
aprender a se conhecer e se apaixonar e
fazer aquilo que você mais ama mas pode
ser jailton no ame é verdade mas quando
você faz aquilo que você ama todos os
dias e que dá prazer
eu garanto com a minha experiência que
você está muito mais perto de encontrar
o seu propósito e ser um grande vencedor
porque vencer é relativo
o que é vencer pra você pode não ser
vencer pra mim a grande pergunta não é
como eles decidem é porque eles decidem
a final diz com afinal de contas eles
não têm escolhas
quando você descobrir exatamente o que
você tem que fazer
você não vai ter mais escolhas e você
não vai duvidar porque não existe nada
mais importante e nada mais poderoso do
que viver os teus ideais
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]